maybe you heard the story actually you
did because i mentioned it on the show
the other day
the other day postal worker comes out
and alleges fraud
alleges that his supervisor told him
pick up ballots that are illegal
deliver them to me so then the
washington post came out and said
not true this postal worker has recanted
this is fake news
don't spread this story well now
i guess that was supposed to be the end
of the story except that the postal
worker came out and he said
i absolutely did not recant and the
washington post is lying about me
i am right at this very moment looking
at a
article written written by washington
post
says that i uh fabricated the
allegations
of ballot tampering i'm here to say that
i did not recant
my statements that did not happen that's
not what happened
and you will find out so we'll find out
he's going to release a longer video
about this
but it didn't happen now i don't i don't
know
the entirety of his story but what i do
know is something that i've known for a
long time
that the washington post is lying about
it the entire establishment press
which is tied into the establishment
academy which is tied into the
establishment
popular culture which is tied into the
establishment technology which is
tied into the established administrative
government and elected politicians
that is what is trying to win this
election it is not about joe biden
joe biden is nothing he is totally
hollow
if you crack him open he you would you
would find air leaking out there is
nothing
inside he's been in an empty suit his
whole career the same goes for kamala
harris
she's she's articulated more forcefully
certain views it's only
because she's younger i think she licks
her finger puts it up in the air
figures out which way the wind is
blowing i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts